some species of spiders expected to
invade the east coast this spring guys
look at this if that's not bad enough
these things are the size of a child's
hand
and it gets even worse all right they
get to where they're going by
parachuting from the sky using their
webs what one silver lining if there is
any they're harmless to humans or fangs
are too small i don't care i just don't
want to wow wow it looks scary as big as
a child's hand and then they dropped out
what was the name of that
um
arachnophobia yeah
every time the experts always tell you
with spiders the two to avoid are black
widow and brown recluse yes i think we
should add a third option when a spider
is the size of a child's hand and it
jumps down
even if ted says that's harmless if a
spider is parachuting in from the sky
and it looks like the size of a hand i'd
say bail out on that one yeah and we
also have those two spiders here by the
way but we'll talk about the brown
recluse and the black widow black man
i'm well aware all right outside right
now guys looking outside i know that
story gets to me all right clear skies
temperatures are warm too not bad at all
still comfortable this hour and be
comfortable this evening too so that's
good
but then tomorrow
definitely big changes i wanted to check
up on the pollen because of course i'm
sniffling and sneezing too eyes are
watering ash juniper mulberry high
readings right now because we have the
winds kicking up some of that that
pollen right now and it's the time when
things are getting warmer everything's
starting to bloom right now 64 sky
canyon along with centennial hills
providence included their 69 for north
las vegas 70s for the east side sunrise
mountain and whitney ranch mountains
edge 68 for you spring valley you're at
69. green valley 72 along with whitney
ranch 65 for prep and 66 double sixes
for you in boulder city so yeah look at
this we're actually getting some
sprinkles coming down in moapa looks
looks pretty good that we're getting
some rain but really remember it's still
very dry at the surface so a lot of this
is just virga which evaporates or just
turning the sprinkles but we are getting
some raindrops right now in the moapa
valley while we remain dry here
we'll get chances to increase a little
for tomorrow here's what's going to
happen this
trough here is going to dig down even
more we'll get that low to develop and
as it does it will swing through the
region and give us slight rain chances
for tomorrow nothing big we'll call it
hit and miss again like we saw last week
some neighborhoods be dry some could get
some of those isolated raindrops light
rain nothing heavy at all that'll be in
the mainly morning hours and then we get
to midday in the afternoon and all that
starts to go away here's the other big
story so today
71 degrees when that cold front slides
through that cold air gets pulled in
behind it so don't expect tomorrow to
even reach 60. here's our high for
tomorrow 57 we go from 71 today to 57
tomorrow and that is it not even 60
degrees
46 overnight breezy evening but then
chilly and windy overnight and
especially in the morning hours 57
degrees tomorrow windy and colder with
those chances for showers like we talked
about not all areas we'll see raindrops
there's chances out there in some
neighborhoods we'll see those winds 20
to 30 miles per hour even higher gusts
that's the reason for that wind advisory
here are your highs tomorrow all right
70s today 53 summerlin spring valley 56
55 mountains edge only 56 for leonte and
henderson 55 for tomorrow two 54 degrees
for a prompt and 67 for tomorrow
afternoon in lafayette here's your eight
day forecast the good news is each day
gets warmer after tomorrow right it'll
be a chilly chilly friday morning so
keep that in mind weekend looks great
70s mid 70s warmer next week but i'm
really eyeing the weekend you can do all
this all you want during the week just
again don't mess with our weekly don't
mess with it and they're and they're not
we are
going to lose an hour of sleep but
outside of that
i guess i mess with our weekend a little
bit hey you know what we just found out
little known fact chris matthews no fear
of spiders even large ones none that's
how it is we're gonna change that that's
gonna change how about some basketball
big news tonight yeah big night for you